please post that down in the chat thank
you so much
uh sondaria for sharing and also
everyone else
okay great that is great to meet
everyone so moving on
my name is beepsha biswas
and i am the omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users who are part of our
growing biofue matrix community
so as you see here we have a lot of
participants who join us from
everywhere in the world and even in
today's session as you see
that all of you are coming from
different places so
this is a great opportunity to not only
learn
from a session but also interact with
each other and learn from
each other
and now moving on i wanted to introduce
you
to the omixlogic program the omixlogic
transcriptomics program
uh we had organized this uh twice
before this year so this is going to be
the third time that we will be doing
this program
and we had many participants who were
able to successfully complete the
program
and they were undergraduate students
graduate students faculty and phds
and the feedback which was shared by our
previous participants and their progress
is very encouraging to our team as well
as to the participants who will continue
to take these courses
and the main thing is the experience in
designing bioinformatics projects with
the help of
mentor support which is an important
aspect of our omics logic programs which
has helped
many of our previous participants
as you see here urja was a participant
in our research fellowship program
and she completed a project on
differential identification of
biomarkers between neural stem cells and
glioblastoma stem cells
and then she went on to win an award
for doing this project which was a in a
word in a student research congress and
like urja there are other participants
who had
uh participated in different team
challenges
one different awards and continued to do
this
so these are all these uh photos or
screenshots that you can see that
you will be able to see even in our
linkedin channel from different
participants who share this
and now i would want to invite delia
brodsky to speak more about today's
session and
introduce you to ngs4 gene expression
studies
so over to you elia
thank you peeps
okay so welcome everyone to this webinar
uh
for those of you that don't know me uh
my name is ilya brodsky i'm the
co-founder and ceo of pine biotech
what our company does is that we really
have
a vision to enhance human health and
well-being
by enabling biological research and
discovery
providing relevant data solutions and
support
our mission here at pine biotech is to
simplify bioinformatics make it
more accessible helping different types
of users
participate in advanced research one
way that we are doing this is through
our modular and intuitive multi-omics
analysis platform that we will talk
about today
but importantly we appreciate the role
that training
research support and big data analytics
tools
that are designed for different types of
researchers
and different areas in biomedical
discovery
so our mission is really to support
cutting edge research and to solve
the big data challenges we want to make
sure that our solutions are easy to use
and we we engage in these training
programs
so that those that are interested to use
big data
analysis tools can use them effectively
and arrive at sound and reproducible
results
so while we focus on research support
and develop
tools for research we also do a lot of
training and this program
is an important program because we see
many biologists struggling
with the types of data and the types of
insights that these data
can provide that are driving research
ideas
and helping them develop more
competitive and more compelling
research projects so what this program
in transcriptomics will do is introduce
rna-seq processing so you really
understand what the data
represents and where it comes from it
will also allow you to try
different tools that prepare the data
for analysis
explain some of the statistical
principles in
analysis of transcriptomic data whether
it is
a simple experiment with just a couple
of conditions that could be compared or
there's a more complex experiment design
but also
importantly introduce you to machine
learning tools that are commonly used
for analysis of big data sets as you
know these big data sets have been
increasing in their complexity and so
to illustrate how some of these methods
are used
we're going to take a project driven
approach
that explains exactly how these
different aspects fit together
into the analysis process so as you know
next generation sequencing is now a
technology that is well accepted and has
become
very affordable and accessible providing
huge consortia that give us thousand
access to thousands of samples on any
given
type of a phenotype and so we'll talk
about how
phenotypic data that could be
illustrated by cell morphology
or tissue type could be further explored
at the genetic level where we see
genetic variation at the dna level
different aspects of epigenomic
regulation
and then transcriptomics what this data
provides us with
is an ability to infer the
relationship between what is encoded in
the dna
and what we see produced at the protein
level
so at that level it is very interesting
to observe
kind of a snapshot a molecular detailed
snapshot of what's going on
inside tissues cells and individual
organisms so what we'll do in this
program is we'll talk about
how as a method of measuring rna
translation transcriptonic studies
can help detect mrna expression inside
the cell
as an accurate alternative to membrane
protein expression detection
which allows for molecular precision in
diagnostics
and new insights for the development of
treatments based on molecular pathways
so rna-seq as a methodology has
revolutionized the way that biologists
examine transcriptones
and has been successfully applied in
many areas of
basic biological research drug discovery
and also clinical diagnostics and
treatment selection
compared with other technologies like
microarray based transcriptome profiling
pcr quantification rna-seq has
a much wider dynamic range which means
that it can detect
many variations of the same
transcript alternative splicing
avoids a lot of the technical
limitations such as varying probe
performance
and cross hybridization and rnac can
measure the expression levels of
thousands
genes of gene simultaneously and provide
insights into functional pathways
and the regulatory networks in
biological systems
importantly rnac can provide novel
insights into alternative splicing
detect unannotated exons and novel
transcripts
most importantly such detail has already
provided proven to yield significant
discoveries
in many research areas so what this
program will focus on
is to explain how bioinformatics is an
important component of such studies
and is designed around integration of
multiple types of data
transcriptonics being the primary focus
but nevertheless looking at the wider
picture of
how we can understand complex conditions
such as diseases at the subcellular
level
and identify important players in this
network
of associated features how analysis
of these interactions can help us
identify
novel patterns insights biomarkers
and targets for drug design and
repurposing
so biomedical projects that we will use
will show how such aspects of
diagnostics could be applied to cancer
biology
how we can classify different diseases
and stratify patients
understanding different groups and
associations between
biomarker features and patient outcomes
and we'll also look at single cell and
tissue composition
so the program is really designed to
give you
a high level overview of bioinformatics
specifically focus on transcriptomic
data analysis
and then introduce you to some resources
like
projects training materials and
tools that will help you make the most
of rna-seq data
so let me briefly explain how these
different topics are going to be covered
in the upcoming program we will start
with
an overview of tools and resources
we will then go to speak about how to
process
next generation sequencing data that
comes out of the sequencer
and we'll talk about what are
bioinformatics pipelines and what are
some of the
design strategies for these pipelines to
make them
produce insights that we can later on
analyze using downstream analysis tools
then we'll talk about preparing the data
for in-depth analysis it's important to
understand
normalization how the data is
distributed
what are some of the technical
variations that we should eliminate
before we
try to compare different conditions and
try to infer biological meaning
we'll then talk also about a new
um i think paradigm in such data
when we're going from just a couple of
samples per condition
to really tens or even hundreds of
samples
that allow us to train machine learning
models
and design predictive analysis to really
understand
association between clinical and
phenotypic classes and specific
molecular features that we have in our
data we'll then talk about another
emerging technology which is single cell
rna-seq data and
there we'll look at tissue specific
expression based on analysis
of thousands and even millions of cells
at a time
where we can analyze specific variation
and compare that variation
by tissue cell type and association with
different phenotypes the ultimate goal
of this program
is to help you design a project of your
own
and so we will provide you with several
examples but we will also
allow you to try to find
and design a project of your own and to
support
an in-depth research project we will
also introduce you to a variety of tools
but importantly we will guide how that
process happens from the start of
selecting your data
to then designing your analysis and then
finally working through all of the
technical issues that are associated
with that
and to help you make the most of that we
have
a number of mentors that will be helping
uh to go through that process with you
and uh some of those will be speaking
today as well
now the process of this whole program is
designed around a schedule
that you can see here on the screen
starting from december 8th
we will meet two or three times a week
for three weeks but the whole program is
designed around
a month and during this month what we've
seen in the past
is you would be surprised how much
progress you can make as somebody who is
completely new to bioinformatics
or as somebody that knows about some of
the technical aspects of bioinformatics
but has never really applied them
to your own research project so that's
really the objective of this program
now this program consists of several
elements that are
built to work together to help you make
the most
out of the program and that includes
interactive sessions
where we meet in a group setting
go over the material answer questions
and try some practical assignments
together
but in between sessions you will have
access to self-guided study materials
and those materials are designed
to break down the complex topics that
require some
in-depth review review additional
research
materials that will help you understand
the problems that we are solving
and also some practical assignments that
are going to be done
both using a an intuitive platform that
i'll show in just a moment
as well as some practical assignments in
coding that
opt that are optional but will help you
understand what goes into producing
different types of data structures
visualization of those data structures
different types of analysis techniques
and biological interpretation
so the online coursework is designed to
help you study independently and will
help you prepare for the different
interactive sessions to make the most of
them
during those asynchronous materials you
will be able to watch videos review the
text
and really understand the details behind
some of the things that we are speaking
now in these courses you will find
important information that will help you
keep track of important words uh
understanding
some of the research reasoning behind
what we are discussing
and really understand how all of this
fits together so it's a very
methodological process of going through
the material
that if you already know you will be
able to
kind of skip over now you will be able
to download all of these materials as
pdfs and make sure that you understand
all of these um and and can have them
for later as well
so as i mentioned there are also
practical assignments and this is an
important part of bioinformatics that
we don't only speak about how
bioinformatics is applied but we
actually try to do it ourselves
and so here you will find specific types
of reviewed
assignments that you submit and get
feedback on
and also uh get to try some of the tools
both as a interactive platform that i
will show in just a second
uh but also uh you will see how the
platform
helps you in helps introduce you to the
details of the methods that we will
discuss
so let me show you briefly what that
really will look like
uh for those of you that want to follow
along
you can go to server.tb
so i'll just put the link here in
the chat
thank you bibza so let's go over uh
to this uh platform just so that you
have a really
clear sense of what we are going to be
doing
so this is the t-biome for platform you
can see server.tbio.info
the platform allows processing analysis
and visualization
of multiple types of omics data so
that's why we're talking about a
multi-omics
integration logic in a lot of our
programs
this logic is circled around processing
tools
and then downstream analysis tools that
i'll talk about in a second
so for transcriptomics we will explore
how you can analyze specific types of
output data from a sequencer which come
in a format
that contains short sequences of reads
then those reads are processed to
eliminate technical variation
and after those are trimmed out and
pre-processed you can proceed to go on
to
mapping to the reference genome now that
could be done using
several different strategies it could be
a detailed view
of alternative uh alternative splicing
events
it could be a mapping on the
transcriptome
or it could be what's called a joint
strategy so
the strategy that combines both mapping
onto the whole
genome preparing a novel transcriptome
and then mapping on to that transcript
done now these are different strategies
that are important to understand because
they play a role
in our ability to ask specific questions
of the data
and have accurate information for us to
be able to validate our assumptions
based on what we find in the original
data that came out of the sequence
so we'll talk about some of these
pipelines we'll also talk about
some of the variation of the pipelines
and some of the downstream analysis
where you will find
such popular packages as dc and others
so importantly in this process
you will be able to understand the logic
behind
what we did understand how each one of
the methods
is addressing a practical challenge
and then see the results in uh for
yourself in the context of a project
right so really understanding
the biological clinical and research
significance of a project data set
so as you go through this process you
will find that
some of the methods provide very
standard outputs
and those outputs have to be expanded on
so you might want to modify the way that
you visualize
maybe change some of the settings so you
really need more flexibility
and to provide you with an insight on
how to address some of those questions
we have designed some practical
assignments that you will see as we go
through the program
using coding exercises
in these coding exercises you will get
an introduction
to methods of using
python and r bio python
and different packages in r
to really go through some of the
downstream analysis
be able to load your data and visualize
your results
so just to again illustrate what those
will look like
i'm just going to show you a quick
example in r
so in this program we will for example
focus on
differential gene expression and so
after you've learned about differential
gene expression
you will get a breakdown of how the data
is loaded in and prepared for analysis
after you've gone through that you will
be able to
run your analysis right here
in the browser and so what's important
here
is that we will go through some examples
that have variations
at the level of the input data
that you see right here but running this
in the browser provides you with
a problem-free and
bug-free environment where you can get
your results and we can all do this
in the context of a single session so
you don't
only get to learn about the code you
also get to run it
and we get to compare results at the end
so as we talk about this program as i
mentioned
the tools are a critical important part
of this program and they are not
designed for just people that know how
to code or for bioinformaticians
they're designed for biologists and
clinicians so anybody can
learn from this experience after you've
learned how to prepare the pipelines and
you understand
each individual method you'll be able to
produce outputs
that explain what the data shows
from a biological perspective so we'll
go through stages of
statistical analysis but also downstream
interpretation in terms of pathway
annotation
and in terms of our ability to think of
the biological implications of the
variation that we found
but importantly we'll go through an
in-depth view because many of the
biologists don't really understand
what goes into preparing the data and
how variation
in the processing pipelines plays an
important role
in your ability to make certain
assumptions and
interpretations of the data so we'll
we'll talk about
many of the important steps of
pre-processing understanding the data
being able to do exploratory analysis as
well
to help you go through that it will not
be enough to just
be in the sessions you really do have to
go through the synchronous materials
to get all of that completed on your own
and here i want to say that also for
those that cannot attend the interactive
sessions
we are providing these materials as a
separate resource that you can get
access
and do them on your own time and i think
that
going through the explanations and also
doing the practical assignments
will help you understand what goes on to
understanding your data
and then trying to work with that data
so that it makes a lot more sense
once we get to data mining and
classification i think that's where
a lot of programs skip over the basics
to go to the more interesting things and
i think that you know
big data has been playing a major role
in how research has been changing over
the past
decade and here the introduction of
machine learning tools
have uh transformed our ability to deal
with
the emergence of these comprehensive
data sets that allow us to really
ask complex questions and get predictive
uh
answers about some of the um some of the
conditions that we have so
in this program we'll talk about a lot
of the typical approaches
for supervised and unsupervised data
analysis uh using data mining and
classification
really understanding how the different
methods allow us to ask
different types of questions and uh
provide us with different types of
uh outcomes and as i mentioned uh these
outcomes are going to be
based on biological examples uh and
we'll go from
a high level introduction of the logic
all the way into being able to code
this kind of analysis you're on your own
starting with the code playground that i
just briefly showed
and eventually going on to try to apply
those
on your own system if you wish so really
it's a combination of a variety of tools
and resources
and hopefully many of you that join will
will find that
an intuitive experience because it
connects all of these resources together
under your own profile and at the end of
the session
vipsa will go through some of the stages
of registration
and preparing your profile so that you
can make the most
out of this experience now one of the
people on our team that will be
mentoring you throughout the session is
an experienced
bioinformatician she has a phd in
bioinformatics
and she will be guiding you through some
of the materials
that are a part of this program so i
want to introduce you to
dr harpreet kaur she
is an omics logic trainer today but she
recently
did her phd with several publications
focusing on liver cancer
in her current research she continues to
apply uh machine learning tools and
multi armix integration tools
to really understand the biological
drivers of this disease
uh harpreet uh let me pass it on to you
thank you
let me share my screen
hello everyone my name is harpreet kaur
and i have a phd in bioinformatics
my research is on biomarker discovery
for diagnosis
and prognosis of liver cancer
so what inspired me to study liver
cancer for my doctor research
is the high mortality rate of this
malignancy
and lack of precise biomarker that can
help diagnose liver cancer at an early
stage
worldwide liver cancer is considered as
sixth major
cancer in terms of incidence and fourth
in terms of mortality
it is that often a time misdiagnosed
or detected too late for an effective
treatment
another factor that contribute to
poor outcome of the liver cancer patient
is the frequent reoccurrence of the
tumor
so with these concern in mind i have
framed number of research receptive
with my collaborators to address these
issues using
various bioinformatics techniques
for the first part of this research
project
we used large-scale transcriptomics data
to identify a diagnostic biomarker panel
for hepatocellular carcinoma which is
primary liver malignancy
so in this study we employed 30 data
sets
containing nearly 4000 samples to
elucidate transcriptomics biomarker
panel
for diagnosis and prognosis of liver
cancer
implementing various statistical and
bioinformatics
techniques
for the next part of this research
project we use
transcriptomics and methylation data to
identify
a biomarker panel for stage
classification
of hepatocellular carcinoma here
we employ tcga data of 350 samples
and elucidate 51 features that
include 30 rna transcripts and 21
methylation cpg sites using a number of
data mining techniques
the navy's model classified early in the
late stage sample
of scc with nearly 79
accuracy
for the third part of this research
project
we use transcriptomics data to
scrutinize diagnostic biomarker panel
for chlangiocarcinoma which is another
major labor malignancy
so in this study we employed nine data
sets
containing 350 colon geocarcinoma
133 adjacent non-tumorous
and 90 hcc samples to scrutinize
chlangiocarcinomas specific
transcriptomic signatures
implementing a number of data mining
techniques
like extra tree svm random forest
logistic regression
lda etc so in conclusion
during this whole research project we
identified
a universally platform independent
three gene based biomarker that can
predict hcc
samples with high precision and also
possess prognostic potential
then we identified a three gene based
signature
that is specific to chlangiocarcinoma
and they are capable
to discriminate cca from hcc in the
normal samples
at last we identify a 51 features
that include 30 rna transcript and 21
methylation cpt size
that can predict hcc at an early stage
so in my current role i am omiks logic
bioinformatics trainer
with time biotech i am assisting
participants to learn about data
analysis
machine learning and data visualization
in application to last
large datasets to use in biomedical
research
besides i am involved in designing
different research projects
using publicly available data sets
so in continuation of my liver cancer
research background
here i am working on the project
involved multiomics data integration
of liver cancer patient to find out
molecular signature
that are associated with clinical and
demographic phenotypes
of the liver cancer patients
where we not just use transcriptomics
data
but we have also explored mi rna and
clinical data that can be integrated
in a multi-omics multi-omics data
integration approach
here we implemented various multi-omics
data integration tools like
snf i cluster plus o2 plus etc that are
integrated on t by enforce server that
has already elia has shown you
so finally we are we are trying to
understand how multi-omics data
integration analysis can provide us the
holistic picture
of this lethal malignancy and also how
they are associated with diverse
clinical phenotypes like
tumor stage risk factors rays
and gender of the patients so
participants can explore this project
during
this program to get a better
understanding
i am looking forward to being your
mentor during this upcoming omics logic
transcriptomics program
and will help all of you learn about
data analysis
machine learning and visualization in
application
to biomedical data sets so now i would
like pass this session back to india
so over to you ilya
thank you harpreet um so as you can see
the ability to work with data and ask
biological questions really has to be
done
in the context of projects and another
person who is going to be
guiding the participants in project
selection
and making the most out of this program
is dr mohit mizunda
so mohit i would like to ask you to
share a little bit about
how this is going to be done in this
program
sorry yeah hello everyone and thank you
dr
patan india for this wonderful overview
so my name is mohit mazumdar and in my
control i'm working and collaborating
with universities to introduce
innovative curriculum on data driven
biological research
at a high school undergraduate and
postgraduate levels
and developing bioinformatics research
projects
so one of the topics that we wanted to
address today
and one of the main challenges that a
research project
presents is how to get started
right so for a number of years our team
has been working on project driven
bioinformatics training programs
that are designed to help you find
develop and complete such research
projects
so as a result of this experience we
have uh we want to offer you several
suggestions to make so that you make the
most out of your
research project transcriptomics
which encompasses you know assessment of
alternate splicing
alternate adenylation identification of
fusion transcripts
exploration of non-coding rnas
transcendence annotation
and discovery of noble transplants right
that's a lot so hence we can surely say
that
analysis of rna-seq data is a valuable
tool for understanding
cancer mechanism and identifying
biomarkers
so in this program we will work
on this exciting story sorry
so in this program we will work on this
exciting project that i wanted to show
you
[Music]
so
so this in this project we will use
translational research and biomarker
discovery
where we will be looking at cancer
subtype characterization
associating technical skill sets that we
learn
that how to process the data eliminate
technical issues
and use machine learning tools to
extract meaningful insights from complex
molecular data sets
so another project that will be a part
of this entire training
so this project was inspired by demian
at all
so modeling precision treatment for
breast cancer
so which is an this is an analysis of
over 70 different
best cancer cell lines and over 19
different
therapeutic agents so this project
includes
include smp data to microarray data on
type of microarray data
rna-seq data so the whole transcriptome
data
exium data and also
genome-wide methylation data which is
the epigenetic data
so you already we discussed about the
tcga project and another set of
specialization
are the infectious disease related
projects
so the application of transcriptomic
data is
actually providing private information
in infectious disease research
so for example host transcriptomics in
tb and other diseases is a powerful
approach
for discovery of immune signatures so
transcript
for example if you take translator
analysis of
human samples that can provide insights
into
which genes are expressed in a sample
tissue and by comparing such
transcriptomic profiles
in samples from subjects with a disease
versus a subject without a disease
so it is possible to identify genes that
differs in their expression between the
groups
and thus it provides us a picture of a
disease signature
right so as uh and one of the major
advantages
of learning from the examples that i
showed you and then
hands-on exercises so you can quickly
adapt
adopt and work on your own independent
project
so these interesting research projects
are proposed by
our previous participants from different
programs by utilizing the public
repositories
and in this program we will learn how to
navigate navigate through different
specialized repositories like ncbi
uniprot tcga and several other databases
so we have been collaboratively working
with several universities
and reaching out to others to help
implement data-driven
project-based learning that enables
students at a young age
to ask significant biological questions
and
and also to faculty to leverage their
knack of research
so we have been working on several
bioinformatics projects with
these faculties so our collaborators
are effectively utilizing this
technology not only for education and
training
but also to develop collaborative
training programs and funding proposals
to support student research projects so
dr harshita here
specializes in botany and wants to
contribute to agricultural research
using bioinformatics tool
bioinformatics tools investigating the
genetic data from
tomato another example here
is from a student so many proposals from
group of students are really
like have been really very exciting for
example a group
led by sarah here uh she wishes to find
out
about specific molecular pathways that
are responsible
for this amazing stress adaptation
in target tardigrades
such an another example of such study is
by
nab energy from ju who wants to study
the lipid biosynthetic pathways
in a plant uh called psy symplocos
sorry simplocus so uh
the idea is to find out uh significantly
uh differentially expressed genes
responsible for
you know lipid production so that can
help in biotechnology so the application
uh varies from agriculture biotechnology
infectious diseases
uh cancer and many of our uh previous
uh participants had this this chance
to work on this different research
projects
and present this uh analysis in repeated
conferences
and workshops and publish online
so that's about the projects
and the research that we are being uh
that we have been doing and contributing
to
and to tell you more i would like to
invite biepsha
um about the program so over to you
okay thank you so much uh dr mohit
i will be uh taking everyone through
uh the registration process and as
i'm going forward i see that there are
some questions
uh in the chat whether you receive a
webinar certificate for this one
uh we do not give out a certificate for
this particular webinar
but all of our programs and a few of the
free resources that
i will be introducing you to today will
have certificates of their own which you
can take
after this program is over so to join
the upcoming transcriptomics program
this is the link we will also email you
all this link via email
if you're already registered and joining
us
so if you go to this website you will be
able to see
uh details about this program okay nidhi
has a question how frequently these
programs are designed
so typically uh these different
multi-omics programs
are repeated once or twice a year
so as i mentioned before the
transcriptomics program is being
repeated for the third time this year
and uh of course in the next upcoming
year we will have
the program again um though right now we
do not have any dates for it yet
but we continue to repeat these programs
because
uh these are very basic stepping uh
stone
kind of introduction for students
yes uh mansi all of it is related to
bioinformatics
everything that you see here these are
all related to
bioinformatics topics so we this program
specifically today is related to
transcriptomics rna-seq analysis
and we also have programs related to
metagenomics or microbiome
data analysis we have programs on
infectious diseases so
there are different programs that we do
all throughout the year
uh yeah sure so we will reach out to you
regarding uh
the presentation or the video of this
program
later on via email now uh just to show
you how you all can register again
as i was pointing out yes
i will come to that uh in a moment
for the pricing in inr so as you see in
this page you will be able to
get uh introduced
to this program and you can see the
entire syllabus so we are starting the
program next wednesday
uh december 9th and the program
will have live sessions until december
23rd the program does not
end on december 23rd these are the
duration of the different online classes
or online sessions like
today and after december 23rd you will
have about
two to three weeks until january 9th
to work together to complete all of the
different courses that are there go
through the different resources
as well as if you want to work on your
own individual project
now i would quickly want to go ahead and
address some of the questions that are
there in the chat
and then move forward from here so to
know about this program
if you click on get started we offer
three different levels if you are a
beginner or if you are somebody who is
just starting for
the first time and you are getting
introduced to bioinformatics yes
if you have not studied biofuel matrix
you can still
go ahead and join the program and the
reason is because
we will be having classes like this
where you will be able to interact with
the mentors you met
today and and who spoke to you
previously
and they will answer those questions for
you we have courses
i will give you an example of those
courses where you will be able to
go through these uh different materials
which are very very basic
and takes you right from a very
introductory level
to a more advanced level so yes you
would be able to
do that but of course it also depends
that you are able to make time for it
and give time to it
so that is there so this is the beginner
session so if you are just joining the
program for the first time
then all you need to do is you can sign
up for this
so 150 usd
is in inr exactly
is equal to okay i would have to check
this up because i'm not
really sure but let me
just pull it up for you okay so it comes
down to around
11 000 ir and we will be getting back
via email so you
if you have any other exact questions
like you know how
much these uh pricing comes to in your
value you can just let us know via email
and i will be responding
because it's not possible to tell to
everybody because all of you are joining
from different
countries around the world so this is
the standard pricing
and here are the payment options so you
can check out via here
and moving on so what do you do
once you are signed up so how do you get
access to these different resources
so the first resource that every person
who joins this program
has access to is an organization page
so the organization page is like
what you can call a classroom every
member of this program
will be part of this organization page
and you can only get access to this page
once you're registered for the program
so when you come down you will be able
to see all the different
events for the program so see if we are
starting on 9th
december with the overview of the
program then we
go with 11 december with processing of
gene expression data
we are going into more details then we
are exploring gene expression tables and
learning about statistical analysis on
14th december
and so on and so forth so you see there
are
sessions dedicated to learning about
machine learning
and single cell transcriptomics as elia
was talking about earlier
so you will be able to go through all of
these things
right here in this one page which you
will have access to so that you can
access all of your resources right from
there
so one of the resources that you see
here is a forum so i'll just give you an
overview of what a forum looks like
so basically the forum will have several
different
topics so this is an example of an old
forum
that i wanted to just show you so each
of you will be able to post
questions get those questions answered
right here in the forum
in case you are missing a session or if
you have
um questions that you don't get answered
or you're going through the courses and
you have these
doubts and we are not meeting at that
point of time you can just post on the
forum and
one of our team members would be able to
get back to you so we also have another
question here
do we have to do the program live yes so
as i showed these scheduled classes
are going to be live sessions but
they're also going to be recorded like
we are recording it today
so in case you are not able to make
yourself available for the scheduled
classes you can also
take this entire course asynchronously
wherein
we will be emailing you the video
recording of the sessions
that you can see and along with it you
will also be able to go through the
different courses
that are available so there are
different courses which elio also showed
you we have transcriptomics
one to transcriptomics four and there
are also other several different courses
that you can take
so you will also be able to take these
courses asynchronously
as well and if you have any questions
we also have the option for one-on-one
mentor sessions where
if you have a lot of questions and you
have progress really well
and you have a certain in-depth
questions or some problems with your
assignment you can actually email us and
request for that session as well so that
is also available
in case you want to go forward with it
and now i want to show you
uh what your profile will look like so
this is an example
from a participant who recently
completed our last
transcriptomics program which we had in
september so as you see tapestry here
she has completed the program she has
over 14
810 points and the interesting part
about
these points is the fact that these
points are collected
each time you do a course any of the
courses
that you do here will earn you around
500 points
and elia also showed you the server t by
4 platform
so the more pipelines you run on the
server t by info platform
you will be getting points for them also
for the platform where we teach about
r and python the codemix logic uh which
is right
this one you will also get points for
this so everything is
associated with your profile so you are
not only able
to do the program but you can actually
see your progress
right from day one uh to the last day of
the program and
if i can just show you for tapashri you
can see the number of courses she has
completed during that time period
the number of pipelines she has run
right here
so this is exactly how you can also
track your own progress and we can also
see whether
you are able to progress further so if
there is any problem you can actually
get back to us
and we can communicate with you and help
you sort that out
so that is the support that we provide
for all of our programs whether you're
joining it
in the next week or in the next year
and besides these resources as of course
you will have
educational access to this platform
which is our data analysis platform
and we will actually go on step by step
through these different logic of
analysis like
what is the utility of these different
pipelines
and there are different assignments as
well within the courses which will
help you to look at the different data
sets and work with this different types
of multi-omics
logic and analysis and of course as i
mentioned you will also have access to
the code omits logic playground
as well for learning rn python as elia
has shown you before
so do you all have any other questions
that i can help answer if you have any
questions
please let me know i can take a moment
to answer them
if you do not have any questions uh
right
now okay yes so andrea has another
question
uh do we can you buy courses separately
or is it per month only
so for this program you do not have to
buy the courses separately
like all of these resources will come
under whatever you're paying for the
program right here
which is a 150 which comes with both the
courses
resources also free access to all the
premium courses which are available
on the codemix logic and the mentor
support
as well as the project if you are
attempting to do the project
then also it covers it all but if you
are interested
in exploring or taking up a course on
its own
i can send you the link for that after
the session so if you can leave your
email in the chat box then i would be
able to reach out to you and we can
you can also take up each of the single
courses but
um only that those courses would be self
study once or asynchronous courses
and it does not come with mentor support
but definitely the courses are very very
detailed so you would be able to
go through them yourself do we have
any other questions and thank you so
much saunder for
sharing this uh the project
uh is a publishable project okay so i
will
show you some project examples that we
have
from our previous participants uh who
were part of the program
so to publish a project as you know
uh takes a long time and this program is
only a one month program
but if you are interested only in
working on an rmac
project or any other project for that
matter we also have a
research fellowship program that you can
actually take a look at
so that research fellowship is offered
for either
three months or six months and
it will be helpful for you if you are
thinking of doing a project
in the long run okay i hope andrea that
answers your question
and if you need more information i can
email you that as well
for pratik do we need to know the
computer languages for these courses
uh so no pratik you do not need to know
any computer languages for
any of these courses because everything
is
built for you writer in the cloud so it
does not require you
to know the programming languages if you
already know then that is really really
great
but in case you do not do this no reason
that you have to
start learning it before the program or
something you can actually take these
courses without having any prior
knowledge of car or python
or even about algorithms in bifo matrix
which you will see
in the different pipelines that are
shown out here so
this is why the platform is a very very
student friendly
and great for beginners to start with
who are not very familiar with the
more advanced ways of biofue matrix
analysis
okay
all right i will send you the info
andrea thank you
and thank you everybody for sharing your
email ids
so if you all have any questions
beyond the session that you would want
to inquire about
i'm available at marketing at find.bio
and you can also reach our team here
marketing at pine.bio for these
questions
if you all have any other questions uh i
think
we have a few more minutes like two
three more minutes
before we will conclude today's session
uh you're welcome zorin